honey maybe we should just call it a
night you go ahead I gotta finish these
centerpieces and rearrange the seating
chart
yes
hello Mom now is not the time I just
want to ask is that genetics or is it
like Pilates
we got your gift it's your Something
Borrowed brings you good luck except for
Uncle Greg wounded up decapitated on
that forklift but that's not the knives
fall oh someone just left it in the
bathroom
invited your ex
looks like he's leading a porn Safari
oops he forgot to button his shirt all
the way up
is it time for dinner
you look so much better than the rest of
us I think the left boom is slightly
lower than the right food something
doesn't feel right
[Applause]
s
here's the plan
spray him in the ice
what work right so many steps
not once did I wonder
if I'd be walking handcuffed Through the
Jungle with a live grenade
oh you got it I got it you got it okay
[Music]
Dad we're gonna fix this
I just scrolling on me I wanted
something less traditional
nobody with my family
[Music]
[Music]
your sister
Carol thank you for the cake knife